18 Koko we're gonna introduce some of
our favorite YouTube videos I'm Janet
I'm Koren I'm Carrie we're in
sleater-kinney the video I picked is a
life hack video which I find very
informational this one is 10 amazing
life hacks from crazy Russian hacker
alright guys but this life hack how
often did that happen to you when this
thing pop out on your flip flops are
here and well I found this life hack
that you get this bread clip and you
stick it over here the most entertaining
YouTube video in my opinion is a video
called horses playing with balls
compilation it's kind of surprising the
way a horse loves a giant rubber ball
it's pretty amazing yeah my favorite
youtube video is just one I've seen
recently it's actually not my favorite
but I feel like YouTube is all about
what you're into right now it's just a
guy who has a one-man band in his living
room hit it Joe
[Music]
the last is a sort of Portland centric
choice it's actually a six part series
on one of our Portland Trailblazers his
name is Damian Lillard and it's called
license to Lillard Damian Lillard from
Oakland California Weber State
University a man during the 2012 NBA
Draft it's really great and it shows him
off as the stellar person that he is I
can't go first cuz nice